today's question comes from ryan in
fairmont
i've been making positive changes in my
life but my friends
still see the old me how do i get them
to change
their opinions of me ayo i want to hear
what you think on this one and then i
want to jump in i'm curious this is
going to be good chrissy you don't want
to hear my opinion i do i do i do i do
let's have it i don't care what my old
friends think new friends get new
friends you know
i mean even jesus wasn't accepted by you
know his
friends in his community so um for me
i'm just like hey i'm not going to allow
someone to prevent me from
moving forward if you're going to always
remind me of my past you're going to be
in my past
yeah that's just my philosophy that's
good such a simple
but really profound answer because i
think sometimes we feel bad we feel like
oh should i do something even the
question is
how do i get them to change their
opinions of me and man we get this
confused so often ao
where we think we can change people how
do i get them how do i get my husband on
board how do i get my parents or in-laws
to behave with their money how do i get
someone to do something you can't
you can't get people to do something
that they don't want to do
all you can do is be you the new you
the new and improved you if you're going
places making positive changes like you
said ryan
and it's their choice if they want to go
with you yeah and here's the truth let's
be real
some of the decisions in our past have
hurt people
and so some people cannot get over that
hurt and
that is okay for them as long as you
know you are getting better
you are maturing you are progressing
forward and you are
growing forgive yourself of the
decisions you made in your past
and proceed forward if they cannot do
that
and see that you are a new man a new
woman that is their fault
uh it's not yours how many people are
listening right now that have gone
through this same exact experience when
they start
their debt-free journey how many friends
and family are going you're weird
what do you mean you're using coupons
what do you mean you're not going on
vacation what do you mean you won't go
out to dinner with us and they
and they don't understand and they they
make fun of you and they they tell you
you're stupid and they tell you this is
this who is this dave ramsey guy and all
that
but the reality is if kind of like you
said anthony if you surround yourself
with people that are modeling what the
like kind of life you want to have
people that are wealthy people that have
great marriages people that are great
parents
then you're going to have this awesome
input and influence of people that are
leading you in the direction you want to
go but i will say one
cool thing you might find for all these
people that
that are from your past or even in your
present reminding you of your past
if you keep just being you and you keep
going
places they'll make fun of you for a
while some of them may drop off some of
them
fate may fade into your past some of
them might change their life because of
you yeah
they might stop making fun of you and
say hey can you can i borrow that book
yep
hey can i can i can you tell me how you
did that thing i know i made fun of you
but i'm sorry because i really want what
you have
i want that marriage you have i want i
want that family you have i want that uh
wealth that you have whatever that is so
i just uh as an encouragement to you
ryan i love
love the advice of if they're not coming
with you don't let that hold you back
but at the same time your light
might just inspire them to change their
lives as well so good